huge things for the shoutout to what do
I owe this pleasure
FDC calls me wildly popular PewDiePie if
you ever meet me in person please refer
to me as the wildly popular PewDiePie
basically this happened
PewDiePie and other youtubers took money
from Warner Brothers for positive game
reviews now let's [ __ ] that I'm just
disappointed this is all over my Twitter
feed people are saying PewDiePie took
corporate money to not disclose paid
game reviews hash tag Shane Warner
Brothers and PewDiePie's shady
influencer marketing so it's Shady
it's disgusting bloggers and influencers
have responsibility to disclose so now
that pip I got caught getting paid off
by publishers to shill for games can we
hate him now can we just hate peopIe now
I don't really know what he does but I
never liked him and now I got a reason
to hate that son of a [ __ ] he got paid
and he didn't disclose it that's
disgusting that's despicable [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
oh wait no wait it's right there first
of all this is two years ago second of
all it's right there it's right there
it's right there no one mentions this no
one this video was sponsored by Warner
Brothers basically what happened was
that a lot of youtuber was involved in
this sponsorship but since I'm the
biggest youtuber
my name is the only one that pops up and
basically what happened was that we
weren't required to disclose I still did
it
some other youtubers actually didn't
disclose it but I'm getting all the [ __ ]
for it and it's kind of [ __ ] yes I
could have disclosed it better I could
have put it above the fold so basically
all these news articles are using me as
a click bait putting my name to shame
when I didn't even do anything wrong
The Verge variety polygon recode
Mashable the list goes on and this
person put it out pretty pretty well
they have to see found that Warner
brother was at fault and the virtues
PewDiePie name is clickbait the a reddit
post says this is a terrible article
with a clickbait title if you're
interested in this issue
you're better off simply reading FTC's
press release of course Warner Bros did
not pay PewDiePie for a positive
you as PewDiePie generally doesn't do
reviews everyone's calling me a reviewer
and that is unethical for me to do a
positive review but I'm not a reviewer
and if you watch the video this is what
I say that's disgust I had fun playing
the game [ __ ] you he would never have
said that piece of [ __ ] how dare you
2014 pewdiepie enjoy a game that is
critically acclaimed disgusting can we
all just hate PewDiePie now what they
paid pity pied to do was a paid
promotion which is perfectly legal as
long as it's the closed which is was
which it was why is no one mentioning
this the headline is misleading the
people getting paid to the reviews are
failing to disclose that were other less
known youtubers who would bring in less
clicks according to the FTC it was the
responsibility of Warner Brothers to
ensure that youtubers taking part in
promotion correctly disclose this fact
okay it goes on so you get the point
Thank You Nicholson I appreciate that
you did this here's an important point
this was two years ago and they have to
see didn't release guidelines specific
to YouTube until 2015 and this video was
in 2014 I do want to say that because of
this back then YouTube paid promotion
was a bit of a gray area nevertheless I
still disclaimed it it's there in the
description but this is how it looks
like today I'll make a verbal mention
before the video even begins videos
brought to you by loot crate and the top
line in the description mentions it as
well and this is so you bros can know if
the video is sponsored or not right away
I'm all for disclaiming content I have
no problem with it and I'm gonna keep
doing it and finally the virtuous trash
for using PewDiePie to get views when
all other youtubers who didn't disclose
the Warner Brothers sponsorship at all
this happens time and time again with
media they take they take someone
popular like me and they run whatever
story is gonna get them more clicks and
you know my name gets run in the ground
and a lot of these articles are saying
like we're still waiting for PewDiePie
for a reply we're still waiting for
pre-departure response to this horrible
horrific act that he has committed I
don't [ __ ] need you
I have an audience I can talk to them
you're you're literally insignificant
and that's why you're pulling this [ __ ]
because I think you know it this is my
response now excuse me while I go play
bear simulator the greatest game that
has ever been made and also I have to
disclose this video was sponsored by
csgo lotto thanks for grouping me with
those people at polygon and really
appreciate it we're practically the same
honestly thanks to people who saw
through this [ __ ] and commented and
boasted about it
I really really appreciate that people
see past the headlines because the
problem with this is people read the
headline and they that's all they they
get out of it if I did something wrong I
should have I should be paying the
consequences in this case I don't think
I did anything wrong but that's all for
now I'm sorry this had to take up a
video I'll see you browse in the next
one